what were some mistakes in your career
early on that you made that you make
sure that you don't replicate in terms
of whether it's just working with a
large crew in an outdoor location things
that maybe in the beginning you weren't
sure of and now having had so many
productions under your belt you're more
aware of oh you do absolutely learn from
your mistakes a lot of them are
directorial mistakes some of them are
production mistakes but the number one
rule I have is always trust our instinct
your instinct is never wrong so if you
had a bad feeling about someone you're
about to employ or cast or a location or
scene that's not right it there is a
problem and to acknowledge that and talk
about it that's definitely one of the
things that I live by the other thing is
you just have to be very prepared and
never assume anything like so always see
the set before you shoot it always see
the Wardrobe before you see it on the
actors on the day like never assume
anything is going to be okay on the day
it's just a number one rule that I have
so I'm I'm always making sure I see
everything before we shoot and if I'm
well-prepared and have a good dialogue
with everybody around me and you follow
those rules and generally you should be
okay so when someone throws the don't
worry line it'll be fine which I know
someone who works from their intuition
gets as well what do you say to that
I've done it a few times and it has been
okay but I've also done that it's been
terrible so you just go by that rule no
matter what huh even when I'm absolutely
exhausted like in the last movie we just
finished shooting and we were traveling
to a new location and we could go and
visit the set but was like another hour
and a half diversion and I was exhausted
I just want to go to bed and I said just
got to check it out so it's just one of
those rules that I have just got to see
it before you shoot it
you